okay and in our new story today zoom
announced amazing earnings but their
stock is down 17
let's look at the numbers here zooms q3
uh revenue was 1
billion dollars i kid you not 35
uh increase year over year net income
was 340 million that's up 71 year over
year 2019 total revenue was 330 million
and when you look at that 2019 total
revenue 330 million you know revenue was
1 billion in a quarter so this is a high
growth company super high growth uh
pretty amazing performance
they have uh over 2 500 customers paying
more than 100k a year
those are the wells in the system
that means if you were to put a hundred
if they were paying a hundred dollars
that'd be two hundred fifty thousand if
they're paying a hundred thousand that's
250 million in other words the wells in
their system
are 25 of their revenue their top 2500
customers or 25 percent of their revenue
extraordinary that people are really
paying a lot of money inside
corporations resume and you know what a
hundred thousand or more is actually not
that much if you were a giant company
why wouldn't you pay that what were you
paying cisco previously what were you
what would you be paying webex or go-to
meeting
like
seems actually quite affordable
this is zoom's 14th consecutive quarter
with a trailing 12-month net dollar
expansion rate in customers with more
than 10 employees
above 130 percent
this means they're growing revenue
within existing customers at an absurd
rate which makes sense
net dollar expansion rate basically
means
how much money is being paid by existing
customers so how much more are your
existing customers spending if you think
about zoom
or
slack or
a crm system like
salesforce the more people get value
from it the more the person sitting in
the cubicle next to them or in another
department might deploy that software so
zoom is bottom up sass just like slack
and yammer which david sacks kind of
pioneered this model
people can start using zoom they don't
need permission from anybody in their
i.t department in all likelihood they
start using it they pay for it on their
corporate card then it gets rolled up
into some giant corporate account the
corporate account then expands hey if
you need zoom just email the it
department they'll get you a couple of
licenses the end all this good news
still is resulting in the company coming
back down to earth this year's 35
revenue growth is way less than the
three quarters of a year ago when they
grew over 350 percent when the pandemic
hit how many zoom calls were you doing i
wasn't doing any
before the pandemic and then a hundred
percent of our lives moved on to zoom so
now it's like restream is half my life
zoom is half my life once in a while i
get a microsoft teams or a google
hangouts but not too often
and so
revenue is growing but the multiple
they're trading at has come back down to
earth if you look at this chart if
you're on the youtube channel uh what
you'll see is the price to sales uh in
mid 2020 hit 120x
in other words whatever their top line
sales was
uh they were 120 times that in terms of
the valuation of zoom now it's at a much
more reasonable 20x in other words if
they made a billion this quarter
and they're on a four or five billion
dollar run rate over the next year but
they're growing faster than that but
a four billion dollar run rate okay four
billion times 20 80 billion dollar
market cap so the market cap is coming
back down to earth so
if you look at meme stocks
this is one of the problems with them is
that sometimes people who buy meme
stocks are buying them based on momentum
they think it's going to spike and
they're just flipping the stock when you
have stock flippers who are day traders
the meme stocks then can face this
compression so when you see people
trading at this high sales to the
valuation right ratio that is a huge
problem there was a group of them that
were the chinese stocks uh
which came back down to earth you had
the work from home stocks zoom peloton
etc slack when they were and slack
really didn't go up too much that was
interesting because i think the
microsoft teams headwinds were very
strong
and then of course you have meme stocks
amc
uh peloton to a lesser extent
maybe uh also in that group was gamestop
and
doordash got caught up in that and zoom
work from home maybe even a little bit
of meme in there
and when the actual people who hold
stocks for a decade
like hedge funds or retirement funds
they want to hold on to a million shares
of this company and hold it for a decade
or two like they hold their apple or
their disney and they never want to sell
it they don't want to take the tax hit
okay those folks are not going to buy
the stock when it's trading at 100 x
sales
they'll wait for a pullback and then
they'll buy in i think that's what we're
going to see that's probably why peloton
and some of these other things
will do well of course there was the og
meme stock nikola which remember when i
was giving nicola a hard time saying hey
this company is not worth 40 billion
everybody's like oh that's because your
your friend did another electric car
company whatever [ __ ] and of course
it was a giant scam and i was right so
victory lap here with rivian i saw that
thing go up to 130 140 billion i called
that one out i've been proven right
already i will be proven right that when
that company comes down to 50 40 30
maybe my target 25 billion company
nobody is going to hold these things for
a long time
if they're overpriced why would you hold
an overpriced stock you would cash it in
and then buy the underpriced stocks so
this is one of the problems we have in
the stock market right now is people got
too excited about china too excited
about work from home the compression
happens reality sets in and then you
have these whipsaw moments uh
and what i think we'll see uh is a
flight to revenue producing companies
with great customers which
luckily zoom is one of nobody's
canceling their zoom it's just too good
of a deal it's too cheap too affordable
and too really just too good right it's
a really great product
so uh i think
this is gonna be a huge huge
a company i don't think they're going
anywhere i think they should be buying
companies that probably should have done
secondary and bought companies at that
high price
i think they did buy some
but uh this reminds me a little bit of
the silicon valley famous talk one we've
had for many decades in the tech
business which is revenue equals death
and i'll leave you with this quick
50-second clip of uh russ hanneman
talking about revenue versus pre-revenue
companies couple of f-bombs or a bleep
in there see you on the side of 50
seconds richard one potential issue our
hosting fees could become a challenge as
we scale
but we can offset a lot of that once we
get a few customers and start a
subscription revenue model
no no no no no no no revenue i'll call
you back what
why would you go after revenue
because to make money
no
if you show revenue people will ask how
much and it will never be enough the
company that was the 100x or the 1000x
or becomes the 2x dog but if you have no
revenue you can say your pre-revenue
you're a potential pure play
it's not about how much you earn it's
about what you're worth and who's worth
the most
companies that lose money pinterest
snapchat no revenue amazon has lost
money every quarter for the last 25
years and that bezos [ __ ] is the
king the king there's no revenue no one
wants to see revenue
that's hilarious and then they ha the
part of the clip that's cut out is at
the end he goes you guys know what roi
is right and they're like return on
investment he's like no radio on
internet which is the tip-off that this
character is partially based on mark
cuban who did broadcast.com
famously and sold it to yahoo at the
peak
before i start the ad read just go to
checklist and you will get a hundred
dollar credit towards your first ad
campaign on linkedin okay let's get to
the ad read here every startup founder
and marketer has been in this situation
you know it well you're planning to
launch your new campaign you know your
audience the team is happy everything's
going according to plan you love your
creative but you got that one thought in
the back of your head don't you how can
i be sure that my acquisition campaign
will drive high impact leads for my
sales team
you need those high quality leads we all
know that and with linkedin ads you
don't need to guess
because when you advertise on linkedin
your message reaches the people who are
ready to engage you they're in the
business mindset you know that linkedin
equals business business equals linkedin
the end over 30 million companies are
active on linkedin today and over 71
percent of professionals use linkedin to
make business decisions so startup
marketers don't wait to start achieving
your brand and lead gen goals no
linkedin is offering our listeners
exclusively a 100 ad credit to get
started today get the hyundai and
get your first linkedin campaign up and
running at linkedin.com checklist
linkedin.com checklist terms and
conditions apply because they're giving
you a hundy